a
elmar travels with some people just
friends
das werden wir jetzt mal sehen weil ich
bin ja ein smarter friend wir machen
hier heute ein test meine damen und
herren und zwar sind die neuen mathe
rätsel
die wir lösen müssen hier ist nämlich
direkt schon das erste rätsel also wir
sehen hier einen handy eingeblendet mit
verschiedenen zahlen und die frage des
roten number one that if you multi play
off its members 1 x 2 sind zwei mal drei
sind sechs mal vier sind 40
und alles x 0 ist 0 als ich unten läuft
jetzt die zeit aber so entweder beliebig
komplett daneben oder ist es wirklich
null also wir sehen 0 0
hawking good and smart 3 + 3 x 3 3 + 3
gleich fragezeichen also punkt vor
strich rechnet das heißt drei mal drei
sind 993 sind 12 -13 9 + 3 sind zwölf
freunde
ich bin echt klug die zeit läuft auch
hier wieder runter eine sekunde und
jetzt ist es auch vorbei und die antwort
meine damen und herren die person redet
hier ist 12 du kannst nicht mit mir
filme das dritte mathe rätsel die wir
uns heute stellen werden ist what is
love auf 2+2 also es ist quasi zwei plus
zwei geteilt durch zwei das heißt
allerdings man teil 2 durch zwei erst
weil freunde punkt vor strich rechne und
zwei plus zwei geteilt durch zwei das
heißt 2 durch zwei ist 1 und 2 + 13 bin
ich schlauer zeit ist auch hier wieder
abgelaufen
jetzt steht hier wieder wurde es half
auf platz zwei durch zwei ist 113 frage
4 ist what ist ford ii die weide bei
hartplatz 15 da muss man ganz kurzen
pause machen natürlich ja okay das ist
eigentlich auf zeit und dann ist es viel
schwieriger aber dann könnte ich hier im
video hat nicht so viel drumherum reden
und so weiter und so fort wenn ich das
eher zu hektisch auf zeit machen würde
aber zurück zum rätsel also was ist 40
durch ein halb +16 also erstmal punkte
vor strich rechnung 40 durch ein halb
durch ein halb heißt im bruch umdrehen
also mal 280 +15 sind 95 das heißt die
zeit läuft wieder ab zeit ist abgelaufen
40 mal zwei erst mal genauso 80 15 95
80 15 95
in
sehr gut rätsel nummer 5 was ist 50
prozent durch 2
das mache ich jetzt mal wirklich auf
zeit 50 prozent ist ein halb geteilt
durch zwei das sind eineinhalb geteilt
durch zwei umdrehen multiplizieren
keine ahnung
50 prozent
durch zwei
das eigentlich umdrehen würde wären es
100 prozent aber das klingt in dem
zusammenhang irgendwie ein bisschen dumm
also ich würde sagen 25 prozent weil
wenn du 50 von der pizza hut und die
teils durch 28 25 prozent allerdings 1
ja ok ja dann wäre 100 prozent richtig
gewesen gut man empfehle ich mein okay
man muss einfach mal logisch denken 50
prozent sind 0,5 geteilt durch zwei
wieso ist da eins richtig
teile nicht durch ein halb sondern durch
2 aber gut freunde das sechste rätsel
how can you make one 1000 bei using a 66
times
was
ich verstehe die frage nicht mal also es
geht hier darum dass wir auf 1000 kommen
müssen allerdings die 8 nur achtmal
benutzen dürfen bei der rechnung aber
freunde ich habe überhaupt keine ahnung
bin ich gespannt auf die antwort eher
mehr schreiben 888 plus 88 8 + 8 + 8
gleich 1000 ja wie soll man innerhalb
von 15 sekunden bitte darauf kommen
rätsel nummer 7 kenia take one from nine
teen and livni
wie soll ich denn 1 von 9
nehmen und dann 1 höher kommen mag ich
weiß nicht ob ich gerade irgendwie
falsch denke oder ob ich auf dem
schlauch steht oder keine ahnung was
aber die antwort jetzt angezeigt wird
hier vorne meine damen und herren ist
20xx 19 x1 mit römischen zahlen
innerhalb von 15 sekunden soll ich
darüber verteilen denken oder brezel
nummer acht ist vielleicht ein bisschen
einfacher aber ich bezweifle er ist weil
sie ja immer ein bisschen schwieriger
wird also eins plus eins plus eins plus
eins plus eins dann wieder 1 bis 11 11
dann wieder 1 bis 1 x 1 das was
ach das ist alles eine rechnung in der
tat punkt vor strich auch hier wieder
einmal 0 ist 0 das heißt 11 15 plus die
ganze sind 10 10 11 +0 sind immer noch
11 11 und 12
also ich würde sagen das sind 12 die
antwort hier wenn ihr das jetzt ja alles
1 bis 2
2000 jahre später
das
das ist falsch ich mache jetzt mal
wieder
kurz den ton an und werden uns mal kurz
anders der tüte zu sagen hat
die mich auch schon gefragt warum hier
kein plus hinter steht aber wir machen
jetzt das letzte rätsel komplett
verarscht selber nachdenken über einen
dummen fragen einsplus sehen sind elf
plus sehen sind 21 und
a
ich dachte erst dass immer eine eins
davor vor die zahl kommen also jetzt ist
hier eine 1 davor dann wird wieder eins
aufaddiert dann kommt wieder eine eins
vor und dahinter dann kommt
nee
das ist ja
schwierig das stimmen also es wird so
sein dass nach der einst eine zahl davor
kommt also wieder eins und dann werden
die beiden zahlen zusammengenommen nur
eins dahinter also zwei und eins dann
werden die zahlen kommen wieder hierhin
dann wieder das erste kommt nämlich nur
eins da vorne eins dahinter dann kommen
21 davor dann werden die drei
zusammengenommen 1
das ist
das ist der so schlau bin ich dann auch
wieder nicht
ja
de
ihr habt dazu keine lösung
vielleicht gibt es dazu
keine lösung
wisst ihr eine lösung ich meinen könnte
es ja auch mal gerne die kommentare
schreiben
nur wenige minuten später
alter
okay einen den kommentaren hat einen
kleinen tipp gegeben aber
ich
ich weiß die lösung freunde schreibt ihr
mann jetzt in die kommentare was ihr
denkt was da rauskommt da vorne bei den
zahlen nacheinander ich lass euch jetzt
mal paar sekunden zeit also schreibt
jetzt mal die kommentare was ihr denkt
was da rauskommt es ist hart schwierig
und man darf wirklich nicht so vorgehen
dass man rechnet und das war der tipp
von dem anderen sondern dass man liest
dass man das ist der tipp ich weiß wo
ich bin gerade wirklich drauf gekommen
ich werde euch jetzt einfach mal sagen
und zwar haben wir hier als erstes
london weil es eine 1 ist das heißt
london also london hierhin was wir hier
dann allerdings haben ist dann also tun
jetzt hier was wir hier jetzt allerdings
haben sowohl to one to one und wenn wir
das jetzt beschreiben wollen haben wir
also und dann haben wir natürlich hier
vorne wieder
wann also hier vorne thierry huon tut
youtube und london also wieder london
und jetzt meine damen und herren was das
hier sein könnte also müsst jetzt
einfach nur dass sie durch zählen
schreibt er das waren die kommentare
alle die es richtig haben werden
versuche ich ein herz zu geben also in
den kommentaren aber ich glaube es
werden dann viel viel viel zu viele
seien also ich versuchte ihm dann
hinterher zu kommen allerdings würde ich
sonst an der stelle das heutige video
auf beenden
ich habe das halt wirklich gesehen und
dachte ok mathe rätsel lohnt sich das
habe dann einfach mal jetzt mit euch
diese rätsel hier gemacht und es ist
schon krass also das letzte rätsel
freunde das ist das hat meinen gehirn
weggeblasen
wenn euch das ganze gefallen hat dann
das gerne machen like da und jetzt kommt
das auto hier
hier können jetzt hier bei den kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen
schenken ihr findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnent seid
könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken dann
bekommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]